i am dead inside
one more step in your necks i don't like
loud noises
and people making a fuss no question
about it i am ready to get hurt again
she makes me feel things she makes all
of us feel things
i just want to get the work over as soon
as possible your department's just you
right yes jim but i am not easy to
manage i wish i didn't have a heart
i'm off to the cheese shop
and i'm buying by the wheel counteroffer
you take me nowhere and i talk to no one
no god no
god please no no no
no i'm just sad because i'm an unlovable
sack of fungus
and i'm gonna be alone forever well i
never thought i'd say this but i think i
know what's going on
in your head oh well then welcome to the
terror dome
it's getting in a little late there this
morning boyle where you been cursing out
my own shadow for hanging out with a
loser like me
i'm gonna murder you i understand just
one second ah
i'm gonna kill myself be myself what
kind of garbage advice is that
i want to punch you in the face so bad
right now
i need you to work out with hope for the
next half hour cool
we did just have lunch last week so i
feel like we've spent enough social time
together
for the foreseeable sorry i annoyed you
with my friendship
since the rejection a great sadness has
enveloped me is he eating soup
on a bench alone well i'm going through
a little bit of a rough patch
a whole year actually i'm just thinking
about how this sea bass is cold
but not as cold and cruel as the hands
of fate that have thrust my entire life
into darkness i understand
nothing how was i supposed to know
there'd be consequences for my actions
enough
chris i'm dying if i don't have some
kids soon i might die
why don't you just have an apple why
don't you mind your business
just push me away everyone else does
okay i can't i cannot have my phone i'm
sorry
i want to be with my phone
i don't want to seem overdramatic but i
don't really care what happens here
don't want to do anything dying the
question was
what is it about me that screams
loser what is happening right now
congratulations universe you win
i need to be included so badly i'll do
whatever you say i literally have zero
pride
sir sir are are
are you listening to me sir sir i'm
talking to you
sir sir are you aware
that there is waste in your water system
oh my resolution was to get more
attention i've decided to stop fighting
it and lean into the fact that i'm an
idiot
i do not apologize unless i think i'm
wrong and if you don't like it you can
leave
i'm fat i'm a fat bald old man
thank you
i really needed this oh god
my mind is going a mile an hour i had
been sitting by the pool
contentedly watching a bee struggle to
avoid drowning and thinking to myself
how i am like that be ah look
who hasn't had gay thoughts pam that's
it
i'm going home i hate
people life sucks nothing good ever
happens what up
personally yeah i think he's a rat i've
only had arlo for a day and a half but
if anything happened to him i would kill
everyone in this room and then myself
chris honestly i'm great i'm just
exploring whatever fun activity pops
into my brain
i'm gonna lose my freaking mind
you better be joking that pen is my best
friend oh i'm fine
it's just that life is pointless and
nothing matters and i'm always tired
also i can't sleep i'm overeating none
of my old hobbies interest me
hey
i am offended i am angry i am very tired
so
i'm gonna take a nap right now you need
help
with my clay mage with your life you are
wildly insanely depressed
depressed i'm the furthest thing from
depressed
i mean look at what i've accomplished do
you see him
do you think a depressed person could
make this
no i never know
let me just say it you've been great
wrong i've been a disaster
you have to get up off the floor now as
far as my friends
what we all pray is the last
do you understand well i don't fully i
think this is a star to my first
friendship
hitchcock hasn't even gotten out of his
chair today i don't know who al gore is
and at this point i'm too afraid to ask
hey so do you want to do something
tonight or oh no not while i'm here i'm
going through something just let me have
this one
yes oh my god that's so hot it was
horrible
oh i'm going to die i'm so tired
everything hurts running is impossible
no arms or legs is basically how you
exist right now kevin you don't do
anything
how much is left in the bank account 18
and four cents whoa still a lot left
over ravi makes me incredibly happy
and ryan puts me through so much drama
so i guess i just have to decide
which of those is more important to me
news flash we're screwed
[Music]
this is devastating i'm inconsolable and
i've killed myself
cool i feel very blessed
[Music]
would say we just stand here in silence
do you like nic cage movies i don't know
who that is only the greatest and most
compelling actor of all time
[Music]
but when you need my help because i am
ruining everything don't look at me
this is my hell just pretend i'm not
here god knows i am
leslie i'm here
we have to go hire a new pr director for
the health department
oh my god i'm so hungover i've never
been this hungover
i feel great i ran 5k this morning
really
no i threw
you